en el vídeo anterior analizamos varios
triángulos similares para encontrar la
relación entre la distancia focal la
distancia del objeto a lente y la
distancia de la imagen al lente pero se
ha movido que hay una relación que es
bastante útil y es la relación entre la
altura del objeto y la altura de la
imagen la altura del objeto la voy a
llamar como h
y la altura de la imagen la voy a
nombrar como h
y ya tenemos todo listo en el vídeo
anterior encontramos que este triángulo
de acá
es similar al triángulo que se encuentra
aquí y a partir de ahí también
encontramos que el triángulo de acá que
estoy señalando es similar también a
este otro triángulo que se encuentra en
este lado
por lo que podemos decir que la relación
de este lado
con respecto al lado b
esta relación de aquí que le voy a
escribir en esta parte la proporción de
a con respecto a b es la misma
proporción de la que se encuentra el
lado que se encuentra opuesto voy a
ponerlo en un color que resalte un poco
más esa misma proporción de la que
tenemos con el lado opuesto a este
ángulo blanco que es este lado que estoy
señalando en azul
es el mismo tamaño de h
o de la altura del objeto y va a tener
la misma proporción del lado que se
encuentra opuesto a este otro ángulo
blanco en este otro triángulo que viene
siendo
este lado a h1 la altura de la imagen /
h
no es h 1 es h y del vídeo anterior
encontramos esta igualdad
y ya que tenemos también nuestro a / b y
aquí ya entrevé pues podemos asumir que
la distancia del objeto entre la
licencia de la imagen va a ser igual a
la altura del objeto entre la altura de
la imagen así que nuestra fórmula de
proporciones distancia del objeto entre
distancia de la imagen es igual a la
altura del objeto entre la altura de la
imagen solo quería mostrar esta relación
útil aprovechando que ya tenemos todo el
análisis que se hizo en el vídeo
anterior para demostrarlo